- Manny was like angry, yapping and,
and this and that. I'm in the bathroom.
-  Oh, you were in the bathroom
when that happened?
- I was in the bathroom.
When I came out the brawl was already...
Because I'm zipping up my pants quickly
and I’m trying to get to see what’s going on.
And I see Zimmer rushing towards
me and I'm like, “What?”
He got close to me, said some bad
words. He actually tried to jab me.
♪♪♪
- [Master Tesfatsion]: So who
we got in the pool hall today?
Pedro Martinez. What's good, baby?
- [Pedro Martínez]: Ay.
All right, all right.
- How you livin'?
- I'm livin' great. Watching you, ready
to play some pool, I'm excited.
Let's get it on, boy.
I haven’t played in a very, very, very long time.
- You got it.
[Balls hitting. Ball dropping into pocket]
- You got one in.
- I got one in. I got lucky.
- Pedro, you're one of my favorite
baseball players of all time.
I love the fiery aggression
that you played with.
It was just so relatable for me,
growing up with nothing
and having that kind of
anger growing up as a kid.
Where did that come from?
- Well it’s a long story man but,
uh, our family was a big family.
Thanks to God, Ramón led the way.
Ramón was still bouncing
in the minor leagues.
It’s a little later for the LA Dodgers.
Didn’t make any money yet.
Mom and dad were left at home with
me and the rest of the kids and uh-
I was dropped at the
Academy really early.
- What age?
- Fourteen-and-a-half, fifteen?
Because I was quick to fight.
- [Laughing]
I can relate.
I was really quick to fight. Any picking on
one of my cousins would be my fight.
Family members, uh, friends.
That would be my fight.
There you go.
- He gonna beat my ass.
- [Laughing]
I mean, I think most
people remember,
from an anger perspective,
the 2003 ALCS.
- It’s that Zimmer incident.
- What happened?
- Well, I threw a ball behind Karim
García and my shoulder was hurting.
And I had men on first and second.
Karim García's the ninth place hitter,
and I'm trying to rush a
fastball up and in on him,
but I did it out of the slide step.
And I took the ball. I'm dragging.
I'm tired. I'm aching.
You can't let the opposition
know that your shoulder hurts.
- That's food. They'll eat you up.
- Exactly. So, the ball
came behind him, and
instead of in front of him,
up here, came behind him.
So, and when he ducked
down the ball hit the bat.
It looks like the ball is over his head.
- Mm-hmm.
- So Zimmer took obsession to that.
They started yapping this and that.
I continue to pitch, got a
ground ball, double play,
but when Karim García is going to second
he almost kills the second baseman.
He was sliding to second and
took my second baseman out.
I just said, “What are you thinking?”
It's a 2 to 1 game or a 3
to 2, something like that.
“Who wants to hit you?
You crazy? Clean it up.”
So Posada popped up, Zimmer popped
up. Everybody started yapping on me.
But I went in, got the inning done. Roger
Clemens throws the ball at Manny.
- Manny Ramírez.
- And then-
- Manny wasn't gonna take that.
- Manny was like angry, yapping and,
and this and that. I'm in the bathroom.
- Oh, you were in the bathroom
when that happened?
- I was in the bathroom.
So I came out a little later.
When I came out the brawl was already...
Because I'm zipping up my pants quickly and,
and I'm trying to get to
see what's going on.
And that's when I hear the
mumbling, kind of behind me.
And I see Zimmer rushing towards
me, and I'm like, “What?”
And that's when he got close
to me, said some bad words
that I didn't expect
from Zimmer either.
He actually tried to jab me.
So I pulled it, and that's why
it looks like I grabbed him.
But in reality, that's the only blemish I
would love to erase from my career.
There hasn't been any other
moment where I felt worse
in my life. I was- I will tell you my life,
than that moment. And that
moment led to a lot more.
- Go ahead, take a shot.
Oo, we got the touch there.
- Yeah there you go.
- [Laughing]
So when you go back to New
York now what is it like?
- You know what, it's a lot better
than, than I ever thought.
People really realize
what I did, how I did it.
I became a Hall of Famer.
I've done so many other things
that people didn't know.
They see that my attitude was
different when I wasn't pitching.
Like, Nomar tying me to the post.
- What happened with that?
- Well, I was like the lucky charm.
I would come out and I would
last for two or three runs,
they would get the two or three runs
and Nomar was hitting like crazy.
And that day I had pitch, so I
was running on the treadmill.
I was doing some more
exercises in the clubhouse
and I hadn't come out and
Nomar was, I guess, 0 for 2.
Nomar did not like that, he went
and grabbed me and goes,
"Ah, you get out here,
you get out here.
You be loud, you do whatever, but
we need to continue to do that."
And Nomar was really superstitious.
So I was so loud all day that even
after we got the game one side,
even Nomar got tired
of me being so loud.
I got to the post and I kept just
yapping and yapping and yapping
and Nomar and Portugal
decided that they had enough
and they tied me up to the post
before I realized what they were doing,
I’m- like tied up with this
heavy tape and I can't move.
Even though I was taped to the
post everybody's laughing
because if a line drive goes through
the dugout, I'm dead meat.
- [Laughing]
- Look at you.
♪♪♪
[Digital beeps from game sounding]
- Let’s get it.
Dirtiest opponent you ever faced?
- Jorge Posada.
- A-Rod or Al Horford?
- Al Horford.
- What’s your signature pitch?
- Fastball.
- Bachata or Merengue?
- Bachata.
- Hardest guy to strike out?
- Edgar Martínez.
- Best pitcher in baseball right now?
- Jacob deGrom.
- Tostones or maduros?
- Tostones, bro, by far.
- Funniest teammate you ever had?
- I would say Manny.
- Better baseball culture, Boston or D.R.?
- I would say D.R.
- Favorite Latin American baseball
player? Five seconds.
- Ah, Vladimir Guerrero.
- Best fans in baseball?
- Boston.
- [Laughing]
That’s a wrap here, Pedro.
Hey, appreciate you for swinging
by here, coming by the pool hall.
It’s been an honor, seriously.
- My pleasure.
- Thank you very much.
Appreciate y’all for watching.
- Let me shoot, man. Let me shoot.
- He gon’ keep shooting. We out.